alright guys here's the topic for today
how to actually get your teens to eat
healthy alright let's talk about that
what you're dealing with is someone who
has very low awareness on the connection
between what they're eating and future
consequences being in practice for 29
years working with tens of thousands of
people I always get into their history I
always see them later in the chain of
events where you know over the years
they might have a slight problem and it
gets worse worse worse until finally
they get motivated where they come in
and try to get help I see people over
here you know they have all sorts of
health problems and so when talking and
consulting with them it becomes very
obvious there's a pattern that starts
here and gets worse gradually to the
point where the person is finally ready
to do something about it what they
really don't realize at the time is that
a lot of these problems even Alzheimer's
take years to develop even diabetes
takes years to develop and it starts
with someone's diet so there's really
just levels of motivation for people to
take action that you have very high
motivation where the person is literally
dying and they're they're willing to do
whatever it takes to change and then you
have people in pain that are very
motivated because there may be in
constant pain or maybe they have a
slight stiffness you they might not be
as motivated or they have no problem or
would they consider no problem let's say
for example to going to a doctor and
they have a symptom and the doctor gives
them a medication so a lot of people
think wow the problem is being
controlled by medication but they don't
realize the problem is still there so
you can take 5-hour energy drink and
feel better you can drink coffee and
feel more energetic the fatigue is still
there you're just stimulating the body
high blood pressure you can control it
with meds pain there's pills for that
inflammation did you realize that the
top selling drugs on planet Earth have
to do with this one category
inflammation so a lot of people have a
lot of inflammation erectile dysfunction
there's drugs
help a person with that does that fix it
diabetes you can take a drug to manage
that so the perception and motivation
unfortunately for a lot of people is low
when on medication because it's being
controlled or managed that's what I call
it managed care I think a big motivator
for people is when they start getting
fat that's what really motivates them
because they don't look good and that
will normally motivate them to change
and in the process they'll step on
something that hopefully gets them
healthy and eventually also getting rid
of these at the same time so you having
a teenager really would like them to
have that realization a lot sooner than
later so we're really dealing with a
problem of low awareness on the
connection between food and your health
and really contains don't even consider
they have a problem at this stage so why
change anything I mean I was in that
boat I basically had this thing in my
mind that I was gonna eat healthy when I
graduated okay it wasn't bad enough and
it wasn't killing me I could cope fine I
had my coffee I had my Rolaids for my
heartburn and I was just I was fine so
of course when I graduated I didn't
change I kept going for years until I
actually hit bottom and be desperate
before I started to reach for some help
alright so this is part of the problem
now let's talk about what to do about it
so I'm getting a teen to change you have
to increase their awareness on the chain
of events that is most likely going to
happen and the connection between what
they're putting the mouse is going to
dramatically affect their well-being
down the road it has to make sense to
them it has to be real but a real big
mistake that parents make is they keep
pushing the solution what they should
eat before the awareness that they even
might potentially have a problem so what
I would do with my kids is I would
always sit down with them with a piece
of paper when they're fully fed and they
don't have any blood sugar issues and
kind of go through some scenarios that
happen with people so they can start
seeing some of the Cascade effects that
happen with the body so I'll actually
show that
that for example let's take belly fat
I'll explain what belly fat is it's it's
basically a situation where your liver
is filled up with fat and it's spilling
over because it can't fit any more fat
it's spilling over around the organs
that's called visceral fat it's fat
around the organs and even in inside
other organs and that will start filling
those organs up until eventually the
arteries become clogged okay
so then when the arteries get clogged
that affects the heart but the fatty
liver over time develops inflammation in
cirrhosis that's scar tissue of your
liver your liver is basically becoming
so damaged that you get high blood
pressure on a permanent basis you can't
bring it down with medication because
the arteries are so hardened so when you
have liver cirrhosis you have scar
tissue that fills up the liver to the
point where your belly starts filling up
with fluid the medical term for that is
called ascites where your gut as a
fluid-filled sac like a basketball that
is very very unhealthy and you have to
go to the doctor and get it drained out
the problem is every two weeks
it comes back why because the liver is
damaged and there's a point of no return
where you're not going to be able to
reverse this right here and with this
comes a lot of other problems high blood
pressure diabetes and by the way did you
realize that 65% of the population in
either diabetic or pre-diabetic that's
greater than 50% of the population so a
lot of people are getting this and what
they don't realize is this starts with
the diet eating the wrong types of foods
so then I'll give them another example
when you're on the wrong diet it creates
a lot of inflammation in your arteries
so let me show you something so we have
the artery which is like the plumbing
and you have all the blood that's goes
through it so the the wall of the artery
starts becoming inflamed when you're on
the wrong eating plan and then when you
have inflammation the body has to heal
it and it heals it with a band-aid so it
starts to develop plaquing okay so it
starts to build up plaque
and more and more and more but what
happens is you don't really feel
anything right away this happens over
years you don't even know you have the
problem until eventually you get a heart
attack did you realize the first symptom
of a heart attack over 50% of time is no
symptoms
you just get a heart attack okay or a
stroke now the big problem with the
stroke is that you don't die half of
your body becomes paralyzed so someone
has to assist you all the time you're
usually in a wheelchair you can't move
around and you're trapped in your body
so this is a situation that could be
totally prevented the way over here
these situations take years to develop
okay then we take another scenario
Alzheimer's okay so I'll explain what
that is it's a advanced brain
degeneration problem where you're losing
your memory okay you don't know where
you are you don't remember names not
good so you don't just one day end up
with Alzheimer's it takes 20 to 30 years
to develop and it starts out with brain
fog that's one of the first symptoms
okay then you get forgetfulness and then
it becomes worse and worse and worse and
over time your brain actually shrinks so
eventually you get diagnosed with
Alzheimer's okay now the problem with
that is that you're gonna have to end up
in a nursing home now the good thing
about a nursing home is that you're
gonna have a wonderful view of the pond
outside you'll be able to play
shuffleboard you get room and board
three square meals they bring you
cookies people will push you around you
get people that will actually bathe you
and you'll be able to play bingo every
so often they have sing-alongs
it's gonna be a wonderful life for you
so all kidding aside this stuff is
actually true this is what's going to
happen these are the patterns that
happen from start to finish so after I
do some enlightening with my teenager I
want them to originate by themself some
type of reach for help I want them to
say okay dad tell me
what do I need to start eating and
that's what my kids did they said okay
what diet do I need to be on and at that
point I'll bring up the solution of you
got it healthy keto in the minute
fasting if you're new to my channel I
put a link down below you can learn
about that but don't give them the
solution until you get them to be aware
of the potential problem that is going
to happen if they don't do something the
whole goal is to get them to change a
lot sooner than later because you want
them to avoid what maybe you went
through my last keto Summit we had 500
people and as I was interviewing people
and talking to people almost every
single person I talked to had to have a
significant health event before they
were motivated to change but wouldn't be
nice to have the awareness now and
actually make changes and have the
correct solution right instead of trying
to search for it so many people might
have the awareness but they're doing the
wrong solution for many years they don't
get better so we really need a
combination of high level of awareness
wanting to get help reaching for help
and the correct solution alright guys
thanks for watching go ahead and try
this out on your kids and make some
comments below on what happens
so if you want more knowledge on how to
create a healthy body subscribe now and
get daily notifications daily
notifications that sounds weird well
I'll just remind you on a daily basis
about that